we got all the fancy gizmos today look
at this
got the xiaomi 13 Ultra with
the camera kit Bluetooth grip right here
special case olive green going reporter
style that's what we're doing here today
and
we're bringing out the Beast find X6 Pro
which one's gonna rain Supreme
let's find out Battle Royale baby
[Music]
thank you
so I wanted to try the portrait mode in
terms of Separation now that's always a
bit tricky when you have these kind of
the the legs of a chair going in
sequence going down the road to see how
natural that looks
here's both of these images right here
now I do notice a difference in terms of
the color science the hasselbot is a
little bit more vibrancy a little bit
more pop to it the like is a little bit
more neutralized but
both are really good in terms of
portrait mode
I'm seeing a little more depth of field
coming out of the 13 Ultra that's not
necessarily a good thing or a bad thing
it just means that depending on the shot
that you want but I would say that the
lens on the Hasselblad at the the wide
one is slightly wider than the 13 Ultra
so there's gonna be a little bit of a
difference in that as well we are
splitting hairs folks you have to Pixel
People to see these differences but to
the average person
the colors and the clarity and the
detail
and just how natural these images look
is
I mean it's the best we've seen out of
2023 thus far this is really setting the
bar anyway let's continue on over this
actually interesting with the Shadows
here let me try with the blue
Hasselblad colors do vet does very well
with blue
look at the blues just pop on them
absolutely gorgeous
oh
that's really really nice these are
mundane shots these are simple shots but
sometimes you get to see the depth in
the color it's a 10-bit color like
coming out of this out of the by the way
true hasslebot color is 16 bit so
there's gonna be a difference from an
x2d and this so for you a camera folks
out there
but it's still capturing a lot of that
that color science that I'm used to
seeing
looking at these two
side by side
I definitely would give this to the
hassleblad look at the blues just come
alive on that and the gold the railing
the detail look at the colors look at
the Reds and the oranges oh oh I'm
definitely gonna say Hasselblad again it
just has that pop to it right it just
has a natural pop now I could get that
kind of pop out of the shot me but I
have to do some post editing but out of
camera
I really like what opel's doing with
this
yeah see
again I better exposure control with the
xiaomi so I'm allowed to capture some of
those highlights and details in the
paint right there with the black and
everything else so it gives it much more
of a the look I was going for versus
with the Oppo it was fighting me on that
again it could be a settings issue I
don't know we've taken enough stationary
objects we're gonna try portrait mode
with people see how this performs with
skin tones and with maintaining the
detail and the fall off and then we'll
get into video let's do that right now
looking for laptop that has more power
and portability look no further than the
AC Usain book 14x OLED it features a
large 70 watt hour battery and stunning
Nano Edge 14.5 inch 2.8 K 120 hertz OLED
foldable display powered by the latest
13 gen Intel Core I9 CPU and RTX 3050
GPU all packed in a thin 16.9 mm chassis
that only weighs 1.5 kilograms so you
can stay focused at work or play for
more information check out asus.com can
I take a photo too
huh
aw
Ian yeah
you're welcome
one two
thank you so much I appreciate it
thank you very much thank you okay so we
just took a nice shot of this gentleman
who was very kind
I'm looking at both of these images
you know what I'm just going to put them
up on the screen
and I think we already know who the
winner is
hasselbot color science is kicked in and
I've already known this with skin tones
it's my favorite camera system to use
for skin tones out of anybody the
closest would be like in Nikon which are
very close second but the depth that
Hasselblad color science captures with
skin tones is just really on another
level and you see it right here out of
the smartphone now I'm gonna try the
front-facing camera for video now
already the Oppo has an edge over the
xiaomi 13 Ultra reason being this can
shoot 4K
the xiaomi 13 Ultra
1080 still I asked xiaomi this question
why have you not activated 4K because I
believe the camera sensor can handle 4K
I don't know they have not given me an
answer hopefully it does come in a
firmware update because there's no
reason why flagship phone of this
stature coming from xiaomi should still
have 1080 as the max for the
front-facing camera no reason for it
anyway let's try right now
doing video
um looking at it right now I'm gonna
walk and talk just a little bit because
the light's pretty good here
how's the microphones we'll get a tour
group around me right there
they're very loud it happens we paid
extra for them again all our videos we
pay extra for these people is that you
mean our budget just goes to having
these people around me so they can you
know
come around it makes it look like we're
you know in a busy street doing more
things than not but uh yeah 4K
what do you guys think let me know in
the comment section below all right so
here is the 13 Ultra with a front-facing
camera I look a little bit washed out I
mean the Opel has seemed to have a
little bit more punch but again that
we're looking off the displays off the
respective phone so it could be
different when we look on the computer
screen Zachy will be the judge of that
but uh yeah I mean I look sharp I look
clear but again we're using a high
resolution display and we'll let you
guys know or let us know in the comment
section below which one do you prefer
okay now we're going reverse camera
rear camera here make sure the lenses
are clean
by the way here's one thing with these
larger camera backs on these phones
they're very prone to smudges so always
clean your cameras before you take a
photo
yeah
that's just you should always do that no
matter what all right so these are the
rear cameras here on the xiaomi uh 13
trip 4K 30p and uh tell us what the
audio sounds like besides this truck
behind me or bus
is this better image quality of course
it'll be better image quality than front
where is it let us know in the comment
section below
there we go 4K 30 out of the 13 Ultra
now here's the rear camera with the
Hasselblad or I should say the Oppo Find
X6 Pro or aka the Hasselblad smartphone
and we're doing 4K as well and let us
know what you think in terms of the
color in terms of the audio which one do
you prefer is the xiaomi or is it the
opal
let us know oh okay so looking at that
video clip right there the oppos hunting
for autofocus it's pulsating and at
times I'm out of focus at the end
shouldn't be this case right
let's try that one more time that was a
really weird situation I've never had
autofocus issues on a smartphone
ever
all right take two let's see if this is
hunting for me or not I'm using
the Opel find X6 Pro again 4k30 it's got
a little bit of a could be 4k60 I don't
know the settings in this are a little
bit it doesn't show you all the details
but um I do know that I'm really hyper
sharp on this and I'm wondering if I'm
out of focus or if it's pulsating or not
let me know if I come forward or come
backward let me know if you notice a
difference
hunting
[Music]
firmware update ASAP outside of that
image quality pretty good not as washed
out as the uh xiaomi audio sound seems
to sound a little bit better but I'm
very hyper sharp on that so probably
need a promise filter for this so I can
at least look a little bit younger I
alright so my final thoughts on these
two phones these are arguably the best
two uh camera systems in smartphones of
2023. and if you don't have them next to
each other either one is really really
good but because I have them next to me
I have to make a decision and it's tough
because
I like a lot of what xiaomi's brought
into the 13 Ultra is it a big difference
in the 13 Pro no it's not but you do
have the camera kit now with this
Bluetooth module grip that makes it more
like a holding up a you know a small
camera you have that uh one inch sensor
actually larger than a winning sensor
for the main camera but the other
cameras sensors are not one inch ois on
all four cameras very fast shutter speed
very good color science that like a look
but
the fine X6 Pro
now in terms of color science
this is where it's really really tricky
because I absolutely love Leica color
science but to give them credit the AI
the software everything else in this is
definitely uh improved and I think that
the colors and how the images look from
Ultra wide to wide still look really
good no matter which camera that you're
using so yeah
um it's a tough battle
but I think I have to give it to the
opal find X6 Pro for this one anyway
guys those are my thoughts on these two
phones let me know your thoughts in the
comment section below which one do you
like find X6 Pro 13 Ultra let me know if
you want to see more of our smartphone
camera battles check out more of our
videos right here
all right
[Music]